the United States
[Applause]
[Music]
The Eyes of Texas used to be a popular
folk tune but today the song could be
about other eyes the eyes of a spy
machine
we live in the United States of
surveillance with cameras like these
increasingly positioned on street
corners and with much more invisible
spying online and on the phone anyone
who's paying attention knows that
privacy could be out the window that's
what former newspaper editor Bill
College says I think the idea of privacy
is gone I think you have to you you have
to adjust to the fact that somebody
somewhere may be watching what you're
doing and it may not be the government
it may be General Motors it may be
to General Telephone and Telegraph it
may be the drugstore on the corner all
of this is not happening by accident
well-funded powerful agencies and
companies are engaged in the business of
keeping tabs on what we do what we say
and what we think
Mass surveillance is the focus of this
new six-part investigative documentary
series examining who is watching whom
and why
thank you
[Music]
some Americans are up in arms including
an internet entrepreneur who says
government spying could be a first step
towards a police state Alfredo Lopez let
me put it this way there is in the
United States all the technology from
drones to computers to surveillance to
day-to-day camera surveillance all over
the country there is a structure and
apparatus for a police state
the United States is not a police state
that is clear we are not that that I
there I draw the line but we can be and
we can be with a flip of the switch
and the real problem is
I'm not sure that
the people of this country have become
have not become sufficiently unconscious
of of their rights and of the
Constitution and the purpose of the
Constitution to really put a halt to
that when it starts and so you know
that's the real battle others believe
spying is now a big industry more about
money allocated out of fear than
stopping terrorism Sam antar is a
convicted felon who says there is a
corporate angle
it's a bigger story than the NSA stories
really corporate surveillance of critics
or corporate surveillance of Rivals
within their own corporations in other
words Executives surveilling rival
Executives these companies are looking
for the Edward snowden's in their own
world yes to many in the world today the
face of America has a big nose for
sniffing and sifting mountains of data
phone calls emails and texts and with
many mouths silenced by paranoia to keep
what they decide is secret secret
even high-tech sector executives are
deeply troubled I'm incredibly
disappointed truthfully I had become
disappointed over the last couple years
I strongly had suspected this like many
others that this was happening but what
I had not realized is that actually now
we've created a situation where all
Commerce is unsafe all Communications
are unsafe you know the most things that
we had expected to be actually have some
level of protection completely
eviscerated just like Toys R Us is one
of our biggest stores for kids secrets
are us has become an American Obsession
and now an explosive and divisive issue
that affects people all over the world
is important that the US is embarrassed
by this
because there isn't a way around it they
should stop it they should stop and
deceased they should sign a treaty
saying they will not conduct cyber War
they should sign a treaty saying they
will respect the human rights of the
whole world taken together America has
become a surveillance industrial state
where everyone's business has become its
business and we're one huge U.S
intelligence agency has been given the
sanction and unlimited amounts of money
to spy on the whole world in this series
you'll meet a former undercover FBI
agent who says government spying is out
of control we want the intelligence
agencies and law enforcement agencies to
have power to go after people who are
doing harm but these programs are being
done regardless of any suspicion of
wrongdoing and a computer whiz who did
the same kind of specialized secret work
that whistleblower Edward Snowden did
but for the military well I mean when
you work the government you're like here
hey I'm here to do a job now and at the
end of the day go home and make sure the
job's gone done right and it's really
that simple
um and the federal government has a lot
of really outstanding people that work
for it I mean high-end high level they
they wake up dedicated to make sure that
it's done to the highest level you can
imagine but sometimes you just have
people that just do their thing you know
they become upset with what they see you
will also hear from Edward snowden's
personal lawyer who says that his leaks
to the public were leaks of conscience
you know Edward Snowden has no desire to
to harm his country in any way he
believes that he's still on the side of
his former colleagues but they just
don't see that we've tilted too far in
the direction of collecting information
on innocent people at the same time
writer Andy Greenberg of Wired Magazine
says snowden's Revelations are leading
to reform it seems that he's their worst
nightmare a kind of Genius employee gone
Rogue what I do see that's kind of
remarkable is that his leaks are already
starting to inspire reforms even as the
government's the Department of Justice
calls for his imprisonments the
president himself is talking about how
the NSA needs to be reformed based on
what he's released
going forward I'm directing the Director
of National Intelligence in consultation
with the attorney general
to annually review for the purposes of
declassification
any future opinions of the court with
broad privacy implications
and to report to me and to Congress on
these efforts
stopping Mass surveillance is also an
issue that is building in intensity
[Applause]
with her as a daughter I cannot try to
explain this situation to my children
does uniting strange bed fellows from
across the political Spectrum I'm proud
to sound here with Democrats with
Republicans with progressives with
Libertarians because this is not this is
not about right and left this is about
right and wrong in this series we'll
tell you what NSA really does how it
works with Telecom and internet
companies and the threat it poses to a
free press and Democratic Values it's
not only a violation of freedom of the
press it's a violation of the Public's
right to know
information is the oxygen of a democracy
it's not just about participating in
Democratic processes it's about being
informed that's what makes democracy
meaningful and when we don't have that
information when a very powerful entity
the government has the information and
the people don't that is not a very
healthy sign we will also show you how
whistleblowers hackers and activists are
fighting back and winning support
worldwide there's been a kind of cat and
mouse game between those surveillars and
the surveills that's been you know going
on for decades and what Wikileaks I
think was the first to show is that the
mice can have some small or even large
victories despite their lack of
resources now you know we see that the
the cats have Crackdown again and that
the surveillance state has responded
but then Snowden you know appeared as
another win for the mice so you know uh
I think that this is going to continue
these sort of um you know kind of Tit
for Tat but it does seem that the the
these Revelations by the mice these
moments when we learn when when
transparency wins out over secrecy
essentially are getting bigger over time
even as protests Mount the United States
government still supports a vast cyber
spying program what I've been very clear
about is is that there has to be a
narrow purpose to it not a broad-based
purpose but it's rather based on a
specific concern around
terrorism or counterproliferation or
human trafficking or something that
I think all of us would say
has to be pursued
President Obama has called for some
minor reforms but critics are not
satisfied there's some things that I
actually like about Barack Obama but I
you know I'm clear about the fact that
politically he is my opponent he's my
enemy and he is clear about the fact
that you have to put into place a con
series of controls that will uh preserve
this social order that's the only
purpose for this stuff many in the media
have been challenging the power of the
surveillance State too relying on leaks
because they can't always get access to
insiders who are afraid to speak
the NSA has invited some journalists in
like for this pro-nsa CBS 60 Minutes
report the agency gave 60 Minutes
unprecedented access to NSA headquarters
where we were able to speak to employees
who have never spoken publicly before
full disclosure I once worked in the
office of the Director of National
Intelligence where I saw firsthand how
secretly the NSA operates senior
correspondent John Miller later left the
network to join the New York Police
Department as an intelligence official
Miller asked some softball questions
ostensibly trying to understand what the
NSA does and doesn't do there's no you
don't hear the calls you don't hear the
call you don't see the name you don't
see the names you just see this number
called that number that this number the
two from number the duration of the call
in the date time group that's all you
get and all we can do is tell the FBI
that number is talking to somebody who
is very bad you ought to go look at it
later a widely read website showcased
another interview by HBO comedian John
Oliver asking what does it say about the
U.S press that the toughest interview
Keith Alexander has is from a comedian
it's been said that your motto was
collect everything
is that true for specific problems right
but you do understand that collect
everything is also the motto of a
hoarder that's the fundamental principle
which ends up with someone living
alongside 1500 copies of newspapers in
the 1950s and six mummified cats former
officials like General Alexander were
off limits to our series as Banny Vines
of the NSA made clear rejecting our
requests for a tour thank you for
writing given the volume of such media
requests we can assist you at this time
with your project
the NSA had been created in secret and
designed to be invisible although it's
hard to hide more than thirty thousand
employees with a vast number of
buildings their tightly guarded
headquarters here in Maryland covers
more than 325 Acres they have a small
army to protect it from enemies foreign
and domestic as well as their own fire
department and SWAT team
yet these days you don't have to get on
the inside for a stage tour of the NSA
to know what's happening and that's
thanks to the Whistleblower they're all
paranoid about one man former contractor
Edward Snowden alone is suspected of
making off with millions of documents
that we have only seen a fraction of
he's been called an Insider threat I'm
just another guy who sits there day to
day in the office watches what happening
what's happening and goes this is
something that's not our place to decide
the public needs to decide whether these
programs and policies are right or wrong
in a recent appearance for Ted an
organization that features diverse
speakers Snowden City would do it all
again despite his notoriety and the
charges against him
I did this to do what was right
and I'm not going to stop my work in the
public interest just to benefit myself
NSA deputy director Rick Legend later
condemned Snowden at another Ted Talk I
do not like the way that he did it I
think there were a number of other ways
that that he could have done that that
would have um not endangered uh our
people and our our uh the people of
other nations uh through losing
visibility into what uh what our
adversaries are doing uh but but I do
think it's an important conversation
snowden's secret files have sparked a
global controversy and debate about the
role of American surveillance that seems
to have the world as its Target and its
fueled debates in almost every country
the damaging here in the United States
because people obviously know what the
government is doing but the Damage Done
internationally is spectacular
not only did they get a lot of
governments really upset with them
that they can do I mean that they can
patch over but masses of people
throughout the world know that the
United States government is surveilling
them and this is a major major uh
problem for them
much of the focus of public anger is
directed at this vast agency known by
its three initials NSA the National
Security Agency also called a shadow
Factory or an enigma wrapped in a riddle
the author of this book journalist James
Bamford has even made a documentary
about the NSA for public TV science
series for those in the know the joke
was always that NSA stood for No Such
Agency for those on the inside the joke
was that NSA stood for never say
anything
Bamford and a small army of critics are
now dueling with former NSA officials
and their Defenders lawyer Robert lit
works for the Director of National
Intelligence and downplays the dangers
of the NSA the intelligence community
and the executive branch is subject to
significant accountability we have
accountability to the Congress people
may question whether that accountability
is good enough whether it's structured
properly but we still have a degree of
accountability and the president of
course is ultimately accountable to the
public the NSA is trying to convince the
public that it's not dangerous but at
the same time and it's become obsessed
with dangers within a so-called Insider
compromise that is now consuming their
attention
in the post-s Snowden period the U.S
government is facing a big problem
internally to deal what they call
Insider threats as many as 4 000 people
they suspect of perhaps getting involved
in leaking documents or being an Insider
threat on the other hand they have a
problem from Congress and the media
which is denouncing the NSA and
denouncing surveillance so they've come
up with a new term and a new program
it's called it's in this report here
National Security through responsible
information sharing now what does that
mean it's not really clear but the idea
is to coordinate the intelligence
community and to have the people in
Washington linked up to the people at
the local level even at the tribal level
on Indian reservations to try to create
a integrated police state apparatus at
least it could be used for that although
right now it's just for responsible
information sharing and one of the
things about this book that I found
interesting was the acronyms the
nicknames of all the organizations that
are part of this network six pages of
acronyms of organizations in the
responsible information sharing
environment
to explore the mentality of analysts and
Tech Wizards who do the same work that
Snowden did we met Brad Sumrall a dark
net programmer and former military
intelligence contractor that you were in
a way doing what Ed Snowden was doing at
one point can you tell us about that
basically the exact same job I mean
depending on what government building
you're in I mean it's still the same
thing it's the same rack of servers you
still have the sipper net there you have
the regular Garrison internet if you
went out into the field you have the
Tactical tactical internets or Networks
so when Snowden was monitoring
information of various kinds uh he he
had I guess clearances did you have
clearances as well yep he's on the
supernet
so in doing all of that stuff were you
very conscious of the material that you
were dealing with being of a high
security nature oh yeah you have all the
sensitive databases right there even as
intelligence agencies try to keep their
stance in line reporters have become
another enemy and maybe a bigger threat
with many hard-hitting reports winning
major media prizes and pitting leaders
of the mainstream press against the lack
of transparency by the NSA awarding the
Pulitzer to Snowden enablers is a
disgrace anything you'd like to say back
to him about that you know I mean I look
at Peter King's condemnation as as an
enormous badge of honor why shouldn't
you Mr Greenwald be charged with a crime
the Scandal that arose in Washington
before our stories began was about the
fact that the Obama Administration is
trying to criminalize investigative
journalism by going through the the
emails and phone records of AP reporters
accusing a Fox News journalist of the
theory that you just embraced being a
co-conspirator with felony in felonies
for working with sources if you want to
embrace that theory it means that every
investigative journalist in the United
States who works with their sources who
receives classified information is a
criminal and it's precisely those
theories and precisely that climate that
has become so menacing in the United
States is why the New Yorkers Jane mayor
said investigative reporting has come to
a standstill what do you say to those
journalists that have been also highly
critical of this kind of reporting on
Revelations people like David Gregory
that are asking if Glenn Grinnell should
be prosecuted it's outrageous I don't
know how he can call himself a
journalist and and talk like that I mean
look this is the job I mean the job is
we're supposed to report the truth if
whistleblowers come forward we're
supposed to take the risk along with
those with those whistleblowers and in
society long ago decided that we're
supposed to have protections when we do
this this is what journalism is about
shining a light on what the most
powerful people in the country are doing
to them in the dark so we're going to
continue to do that no matter what David
Gregory and his friends say this series
will take you to a high-level media
Summit held inside the New York Times
that debated the role of leaks and the
need to defend the Press
well I think there is a need for
pushback this conference is a step in
that direction and there are reporters
uh and even even mainstream uh news
organizations that are pushing back uh
so there's an important fight going on
here the NSA could not have access to as
high a volume of emails and
Communications without the full
cooperation of telecom companies and
internet providers this relationship has
blossomed into a surveillance industrial
complex with a flow of personnel back
and forth between the NSA and its
contractors as the internet expanded
corporations I think saw the possibility
of making huge profits and really jumped
into it very very aggressively but the
important thing to to note is that the
real heavy duty corporate involvement in
the internet is only about six or seven
years old that's when they really swept
in events like 911 enabled the NSA to
grow into a 60 billion dollar Enterprise
with 70 percent or 42 billion going to
contractors some led by former NSA
Executives in October 2001 the NSA had
only given 55 contracts to 144
contractors by October 2003 that number
had grown to
7197 contracts for 4 388 companies
Snowden had been an NSA employee who
left to work for a company called Booze
Allen Hamilton run in part by a former
NSA director private companies like
these were given access to the nsa's top
secrets
this also led to an expansion of spying
even as Government studies found that
the FBI and CIA screwed up by not
applying the intelligence they had but
couldn't process to stopping 9 11. under
pressure from President Bush and vice
president Cheney the agencies decided
that traditional legal restraints no
longer mattered so immediately after 9
11 it was it was somewhat shocking to me
that there was a general
feeling that was being expressed that
the rules didn't matter anymore that
that the FBI had been Unleashed and we
were now allowed to investigate who we
want and not worry about the legal
restraints and it concerned me
greatly because I knew from the history
of the FBI that that would lead the FBI
into a dangerous area that was going to
impact the civil liberties of innocent
people and not improve Security in fact
even harm security and I think that's
essentially what's happened keep in mind
the Patriot Act is what allowed them to
grow they were so you know kind of
insignificant they did so few little
things but then all of a sudden they
became the number one with a big fat
check in addition to their huge budgets
technological Supremacy and backing from
Key politicians who are supposed to
exercise oversight NSA had always
counted on support from a fearful public
that's changing says Attorney Ben
Weisner of the ACLU I think they're so
used to getting their way they're so
used to being able to invoke the threat
of terrorism and having everybody roll
over that they're surprised by this
environment where where those kinds of
dangerous threats are not scaring the
public into submission But ultimately
this is about what they do and not what
they say and I don't think that there is
a great defense no nothing to me because
back in the 1980s was common knowledge
that the NSA was using many of the same
tools that it's alleged or it's come out
to been using today why do you think
that is why are they doing what they're
doing
it's it's not an ideological issue
because you have democratic presidents
you have Republican presidents you have
the far left the far right they all
agree on one thing we all want to know
what everybody else is doing
so spying is is in our gene pool yes
buying is in the American gene pool
unfortunately
coming up next
we're here at the International Spy
Museum in Washington DC there are more
spies here in DC than anywhere else in
the world so it's appropriate that we
have this institution that really tells
the complete story of Espionage
internationally when you travel to
America's capital Washington DC you can
afford the admission you can visit this
International Spy Museum to relive the
glories of the Cold War complete with an
exhibit on James Bond's evil adversaries
what you won't find is any reference to
the current surveillance spying Scandal
the key aspects of Espionage that
deception that uh art of hiding
information and disclosing information
really has remained the same and this is
the capital of it Washington DC
absolutely Washington DC is certainly
the capital of Espionage and the capital
of deception in many ways yes absolutely
outside of Washington in the Maryland
suburbs is the capital of that capital
the National Security Agency
this super secret spy agency is not
hospitable to tourists or most reporters
who want to know what's happening now
we found that out when we were told we
were not welcome at this heavily guarded
Federal facility it has more than 30
thousand employees 32 miles of Roads
across 325 Acres we were threatened with
a 500 fine for even asking about
entering although later the NSA gave us
some footage
these students at a nearby local
University were threatened with arrest
for photographing an NSA building on
their campus where whistleblower Ed
Snowden once worked
I say used to stand for never say
anything this has changed because the
surveillance state is in the news every
day Americans know it exists but few
really understand what it does and how
to find out also don't bother visiting
the NSA website
I'm often asked the question what's more
important civil liberties or national
security it's a false question it's a
false choice at the end of the day we
must do both you only find out what they
want you to know that they are here to
defend and protect you they claim to be
accountable in legal and moral terms
we have to find the way to ensure that
we support the entirety of the
Constitution that was the intention of
the framers of the Constitution that's
what we do on a daily basis at the
National Security Agency
how true is that we will investigate the
claims and the realities in this episode
of America's surveillance state
[Music]
[Applause]
what does the NSA do it's a simple
question but because it's a Top Secret
Agency a clear understanding has been
hard to grasp
the agency is not required to release
even non-classified information
on November 6 1998 and it say for the
first time Declassified this
organization chart of its operations
directorate you'll note some of this
document is blacked out it also only
shows part of nsa's mission including
Military Support
intelligence oversight and policy Global
issues and Military production and here
what they call collection operations
that's another word for electronic
eavesdropping it has become well known
but also controversial because of all
the data that is being collected and
stored you have this incredible
advances in in technology that enable
much more collection than than ever was
possible and a an increase of secrecy
around the program so it's very unclear
still not just what the government is
doing but what legal authorities it
thinks allows it to do what it's doing
Mike German a veteran undercover FBI
agent knows surveillance techniques
because he's used them it's an enormous
problem for the government to know more
about the people than the people know
about what the government's doing and
what we've seen since the terrorist
attacks of 9 11 is that a lot of the
legal restraints that that kept the
government in check after a previous era
of abuse were relaxed or removed
completely in many cases the NSA was
created secretly 60 years ago not by
Congress but by the president as a tool
of the Cold War but it always got less
attention than the Spooks spies and
assassins who built the cia's mistake as
the invulnerable and omnipotent
overthrower of governments and silencer
of America's enemies
CIA scandals including a recently leaked
document detailing its role in torture
and abuse became well known even as the
nsa's better funded operations were
downplayed because they were considered
the province of super nerds boys with
toys Like Satellites cables and
supercomputers NSA hires more
mathematicians than any other Federal
agency Ray McGovern was in the CIA and
Rose to become a briefer of presidents
he worked for seven presidents and nine
directors of Central Intelligence he
says he joined because he believed in
the mission
the ethos of intelligence work that
attracted me was
symbolized by the scriptural quote on
the foyer of the cia's new building it
was new 1963 when I came on under John
Kennedy and it said You shall know the
truth
and the truth shall set you free okay
and I said looked at that and I
remembered the the constant dictum of my
Irish grandmother be truthful and honest
and then you won't give a damn what
anyone says about you okay and so I
looked and I say grandma
if that's true you know no pun intended
it's going to be a good place to work
eventually like many professionals he
became disillusioned retiring early as a
member of the intelligence Community he
came to know the nsa's work well NSA did
play a role we learned things about the
Soviet Union we never would have known
before
it was done with judiciousness and above
all it was done with respect to what
they call the first commandment out
there at Fort Meade Tennessee Thou shalt
not collect information
eavesdrop on Americans without a Court
warrant that was the rule that was the
first commandment when Cheney came in he
said they called The General Hayden who
was head of NSA at the time he said
General Hayden I know about that first
commandment and I said I know about that
forget about it forget about it and that
was before 9 11. so the decision for the
NSA to begin collecting information on
everyone and everything started with a
an order from above oh sure it was Dick
Cheney and George Bush the other thing
of course that needs to be said is that
the technology allowed that for the
first time and so when you had the sort
of the rubric here collect everything
which clearly is them I don't know
collect everything and then they say
well you know what people say what about
the the problem with the haystack
finding a needle in the haystack well
the answer to that they say is you got
to make sure you have the whole Haystack
this NSA document leaked by Ed Snowden
describes their collection program this
way collect it all sniff it all know it
all process it all exploit it all
NSA whistleblower Russ Tice says the
agency is still downplaying its
collecting process to make it sound
harmless
they're lying about what they have and
their capabilities and what they're
doing they're archiving everything
there are there are ideas we'll archive
everything we're going to take
everything and then they say oh well we
we don't collect well then they're lying
of course but their definition of
collect is to have some human analyst
look at at this email or or listen to
this phone call or whatever well of
course that's nonsense they've collected
it and they have it for Lord you know
for in an indefinite period of time but
they're not going to call it collected
until someone looks at it and of course
there's no way we have enough humans on
this planet to listen to every you know
communication that happens they are also
not talking about how collecting
everything makes it harder to produce
relevant intelligence is there a danger
of you know valuable information getting
lost because so much is collected I mean
this is what they said after 9 11 you
know they had information about these
hijackers but nothing was done because
there was so much information they
couldn't figure out who to go after and
and the Boston bombers and the underwear
bombers and the shoe bombers all these
all these things you know because
they've you know they say they're you
got to look for a needle in the haystack
well you know part of my job in that
world was to make sure to First the
limit the size of Haystack that way you
don't have much hay to go through before
to look for the needle and what they're
doing is just dumping on more hay
they're they're you don't have a
haystack anymore you have a mountain of
hay
to go through State surveillance today
is now cheap it's undetectable it's
pervasive and it's available at the
click of a mouse
as a result entire populations rather
than individuals now live under constant
surveillance whistleblower Ed Snowden
went through that hay and saw a lot of
disturbing images Wars and abuses as a
network administrator he had access to
all the databases and soon realized that
he had the power to spy on anyone in a
video prepared for a televised debate he
explained
despite policy policy I as an nsan
sitting at my desk had the technical
authority to wiretap anyone from a
federal judge to the president of the
United States without getting out of my
chair
as long as I had a private email address
and that's not a boast
in fact some of these cases have already
happened in 2009 the New York Times
reported that an NSA analyst used our
state surveillance infrastructure to
improperly access Bill Clinton's email
and other NSA workers have used State
surveillance to spy on their lovers
ex-girlfriends and other individuals who
are obviously not suspected of any crime
at all or any kind of wrongdoing
it's important to note that none of
those individuals were ever charged with
crimes
and we have to ask ourselves why is that
journalist Glenn Greenwald has now
released some of snowden's documents in
his new book that confronts the NSA head
on the same rhetoric is constantly
invoked which is if you shine a light on
what we in political power are doing in
a way that we haven't authorized you to
do you're going to have blood on your
hands I mean there's an obvious irony to
being accused by a U.S general who
served in Iraq of all places of having
blood on your hands or resulting causing
the death of innocent people nobody
could ever surpass Keith Alexander and
his fellow generals and their ability to
do that what we've seen is a expansion
of what we call secret law where they're
either working under authorities that
the American public doesn't know about
or even worse there is a law in the
books but they're interpreting it in a
way that the an objective reading of
that law wouldn't ordinarily allow the
NSA in the hot seat documents leaked by
Edward Snowden show that the NSA may
have been spying on Chancellor Angela
Merkel an old mobile phone number she
used is listed in those documents
Germany not happy soon thanks to the
Snowden disclosures and media
investigations we found out that the NSA
was collecting Intel on 122 foreign
leaders even U.S allies like the
chancellor of Germany and the president
of Brazil 35 leaders had their calls
monitored for Germany it is unacceptable
that the mobile phone of our federal
Chancellor may have been subject
to surveillance activities by our
American partners
for us
spying on close friends and partners is
totally unacceptable the NSA speaks of
its work in neutral and non-threatening
language using terms like collection
telephony metadata what does that mean
we asked former FBI undercover agent
Mike German I mean you would normally
think in the terms of the Fourth
Amendment at any time the government is
collecting information about you
Gathering it putting it in a government
database that that would be collection
but often the way the authorities that
govern
government surveillance are interpreted
sometimes acquisition the acquisition of
information versus the collection of
information are two different things and
they're only considering it collected
once a human being has actually put eyes
on it and processed the information
in May 2014 former NSA director Michael
Hayden shocked a Washington audience
when he said that the NSA uses metadata
to kill people a reference to NSA
providing intelligence to military units
using drones to assassinate people the
Pentagon and the White House consider
enemies Hayden quickly backtracked
saying we don't do that in the U.S
okay we kill people based on metadata
but that's not what we do with this
metadata
okay
thankfully
wow I was working up a sweat there for a
second
he's now working with a former Homeland
Security Chief was also embarrassed in
October 2013 when he was overheard by a
fellow train passenger who began
tweeting the content of his confidential
phone conversation
using a secret fisa Court to do its
bidding the NSA pressed the government
to order phone companies like Verizon a
t Sprint and Nextel to turn over a
massive number of Records later we
learned about a program called prism
here's the secret NSA document that
shows what it does to collect internet
data virtually everything we do and say
online from all the big companies well
they're collecting everything they can
collect and that is everything
they've been doing that without any
adult supervision the White House the
the
Committees in Congress who are supposed
to be exercising oversight right they're
the Overlook committees not the overall
site committees and they're they're
complicit in that not only that but you
have these 15 foe judges from the fisa
court the foreign intelligence
surveillance act Court foe means phony
right yeah f-a-u-x yeah yeah and uh so
what you have Danny and this is
important the first time in my my life
you have the executive
you have
important people in the legislative
branch the heads of the intelligence
committees and you have 15 judges on the
fisa court
all sort of enmeshed all complicit in
this gross violation of the Fourth
Amendment and you start out asking about
NSA what it stands for now it stands for
No Such Amendment
no such Amendment
just to summarize what is NSA NSA is the
largest most costly and most
technologically sophisticated spy
organization the world has ever known it
filters millions of phone calls and
emails an hour it has computers
programmed to watch for hundreds of
thousands of names its computers cost
tens of millions and carry strange names
like black widow they run at special
speeds most of us have never heard of
hundreds of teraflops that can lead to
hundreds of trillions of operations per
second
NSA headquarters is four times bigger
than the U.S capital
I love the place I went into the
military in the Air Force and when
Ronald Reagan was President
um I was I was Full Throttle we were
fighting the Cold War against the evil
Soviet Union and um and I was a full
believer I mean I was gung-ho and and
you know I'd be the guy that would get
in early and stay late and you know I I
wanted to to do my job and I love the
place rust ice typified the NSA
mentality a space engineer he believed
in their clandestine Mission and was
totally dedicated he worked in super
secret so-called black World programs
until he discovered that the satellites
were not just spying on America's
enemies in one of these programs I found
out that we were using our we were using
satellite technology to spy on American
citizens
spy on American citizens yes not
supposed to do that right no in in NSA
every six months you go through a
program where they drill it into your
head we call it you said 18 that you
will not spy on Americans and for one
incident of spinal Americans you can go
to jail for five years for one incident
and they drill that into your head and
work and we all believe that we will
never do this to our fellow citizens
William Binney was a 40-year veteran of
NSA who also went off the reservation
because he saw the agency straying from
its job he was interviewed by democracy
Now the the Congress and the
administration have been have been fed
by the by the intelligence Community
what I call technobabble
in other words they're being Bamboozled
into thinking a certain way that they
have to do this in order to get
terrorists and that's simply false
speaking of terrorists the most dramatic
NSA story we heard came from Thomas
Drake who became an executive at NSA on
the day of a terrorist attack September
2001. almost 3 000 people were murdered
the workforce knew that this was not
just a passing crisis the workforce knew
that we had utterly failed the nation
we under the Constitution the Prima
Constitution government has two primary
responsibilities one is to provide for
the common defense the other is provide
for the general welfare
here utterly fail we had not kept people
out of Harm's Way we had not protected
the nation there was a feeling of guilt
there because the NSA had information on
some of the men who skyjacked those
planes that were flown into buildings
but they did not share it with other
agencies Thomas Drake became an
eyewitness to how the agency changed
so I became eyewitness to NSA unchaining
itself with the approval and the Mandate
of the White House
on chaining itself from the Fourth
Amendment
literally
and entering into a mass surveillance
regime
the likes that history has never seen
before
as he became critical of the agency's
failures he became a whistleblower and
faced years in prison for going public
with NSA failures unlike Edward Snowden
he did not leak masses of documents
that was one of the fundamental rules
whether it was oral communication
whether it's written electronic or later
on even in hard copy it was all
unclassified period what's not
appreciated is that Snowden has been as
careful in assembling information as he
has been in disseminating information if
I had just wanted to harm the U.S you
know that
you could shut down the the surveillance
system in an afternoon
but that's not my intention and I I
think for anyone making that argument
they need to think if they were in my
position and you know you live a
privileged life you you're living in
Hawaii in paradise and making a ton of
money what would it take to make you
leave everything behind
thanks to what we've learned from
snowden's disclosures it seems like all
of us have been reduced to the data we
convey when you engage in electronic
transaction whether it's with your cell
phone with a regular traditional
landline phone uh
with your credit card with your computer
uh the transaction itself the content of
the communications is called content you
know if you buy something at the store
with your credit card what you bought is
is considered content
um but there are all sorts of electronic
Trails left like crumbs that often have
a tremendous amount of very detailed
information about you particularly when
it's gathered in Mass for for example
who you called when you called them how
long you were on on the call with them
where you made the call from that type
of data
collected in Mass can reveal an awful
lot of information about you in May 2014
Washington finally took legal action
against cyber spying by China not the
United States even as some of the
Snowden documents revealed that economic
Espionage is also in nsa's portfolio the
Chinese and U.S critics left at what
they called hypocrisy
the United States deliberately made up
facts using the excuse of so-called
stealing of Secrets online to indict
five Chinese military officials this has
seriously violated the basic principles
of international relations and damaged
Chinese U.S corporation and mutual trust
Americans think it's okay if we spy on
foreigners but it's not okay if we spy
on Americans as if you know the rest of
the world has no right to privacy at all
we are more worried about Al Qaeda than
I think any nation state as a threat to
American lives
but nonetheless we I think we have to
rein in an agency that has the ability
to spy on any innocent citizen with
impunity
of any country in the world I mean when
the world becomes the nsa's panopticon
even with a fig Leaf of privacy around
Americans uh that to me
does seem unacceptable and it turns the
whole world against us coming up next
the NSA and the Press house spying and
intimidation has led America's
mainstream media to push back and
publish leaks and disclosures that would
have once been Unthinkable the Press
versus the NSA
the New York Times is considered
America's most powerful newspaper its
offices near Manhattan's Times Square
projects that power for a media
institution that often sets the
political agenda and tells us what's
important
and yet today there is also Fear and
Loathing inside New York Times newsrooms
where journalists increasingly feel
threatened even intimidated by an
Administration that has prosecuted more
whistleblowers eight and all than any
other in American history
in March 2014 the times Conference
Center hosted a forum to address the
state of press Freedom pact it was like
a media Summit of major players there to
resist the growing power of the
surveillance state
distributed at the event was this 2014
report on attacks on the press the
committee to protect journalists charges
that the NSA puts journalists under a
cloud of Suspicion
[Music]
we're at the New York Times Center in
Manhattan for a conference on sources
and secrets some of the top journalists
in America are here to debate and
discuss the growth of the surveillance
state in America journalists feel
threatened politicians now feel
threatened this seems to be an issue
that's gone from the back pages to the
front page Ralph Engelman works with the
Polk Awards sponsoring a respected
awards ceremony in an industry that is
far more competitive than collaborative
confidentiality of sources is Central to
the work of journalists investigative
journalists in particular and in
addition to the use of the Espionage Act
what we've learned from the the Snowden
Revelations about the NSA how can you
guarantee confidentiality Engelman sees
this event not just as a get-together
for reporters but one with an important
political Mission I think there is
is something that has not been said
directly that needs to be said and that
is that the sort of political context
for this whole crisis in terms of of
Journalism and surveillance
and the the use of the Espionage Act of
1917. if you go back to the original Act
of 1917 it was passed in large measure
to suppress anti-war sentiment sentiment
against U.S entry into the War uh first
world war it's not simply a question of
journalistic practice but it's also a
question of American foreign policy the
ability of journalists and the public to
follow what's going on at issue today is
the case of James risen a Times Reporter
who exposed warrantless wiretapping you
know after we had
reported on the story and nailed it down
we
went to the government for Convent for
comment in fact I went to Michael Hayden
who was then the director of the NSA and
got him on the phone and uh
told him what we were writing and and
before he realized what he was doing he
had given me an on the record comment
and then a sinner very quickly after
that he and the Bush Administration
started putting pressure on my editors
demanding that we not run the story
former veteran CIA analyst Ray McGovern
says that at first there was an effort
to suppress ryzen's story James Horizon
had this story in the summer of 2004. it
was that Dick Cheney and George Bush had
told General Hayden to collect
everything and forget about this first
amendment at NSA about not collecting on
Americans by the court or just collect
everything okay
now that was discovered in the summer of
2004 but the New York Times superiors of
James risen went to the White House and
said
and the election is coming up and so
George Bush said don't that National
Security National Security terrorism
terrorism for National Security do not
publish a story The Times initially sat
on the report but then ryzen told his
boss publisher author solzberger that
this story will be told in his new book
The Times publisher then told the White
House the newspaper would be going ahead
and so Salzburg could calls the White
House and says I'm sorry we're going to
have to publish on that now Bush orders
him into the oval offices tell them no
you can't do that he orders the
publisher of the New York Times into the
White House right and the published in
New York Times and the Washington bureau
chief dutifully show up there and Bush
says he can't do that okay now this is
the 5th of December 2005. you can't do
that okay
and they said well you know hey we held
off for 15 months ago I'd say you know
you got to understand so what happened
here is that the New York Times caved
and Michael Hayden uh was uh was asked
to explain all this in January of 2006
so one month after Verizon's Revelation
he gets up before the national Press
Club and he's asked by Jonathan Landy
it's on it's right on the it's on
YouTube uh General Hayden
um why is it that you have sort of
played fast almost with the Fourth
Amendment Fourth Amendment actually uh
protects all of us against unreasonable
search and seizure
the measure is probable cause I believe
the amendment says unreasonable search
and seizure but does it not say probably
the benefit but the NSA director was
wrong probable cause is in the Fourth
Amendment but ryzen is still being
ordered by the courts to reveal his
source and he's resisting leading to an
ongoing clash and a possible jail term
you're trying to do they're trying to
kind of create a a path for accepted
reporting and that if you as a reporter
go outside those parameters that you'll
be punished and that the sources
that you will that you are trying to
deal with will be prosecuted media
Old-Timers like retired times editors
see more topping sees a larger context
too we're living in a period of uh of
terrorism
of of danger
on questions affecting National Security
and therefore the the whole question of
the role of the press
becomes and its relationship with the
government becomes more and more
important it's important that the public
will become more and more aware of the
problems confronting the Press
journalists in the building like Bill
cobbitch and other former times bureau
chief were also very conscious of what
happened to another building in New York
the World Trade Center creating the
pretext for the rise of massive
government spying when the Trade Center
went down all bets were off who was
going to challenge the government nobody
was not that we didn't do it depressed
didn't do it the government had the
opportunity and George W bush opened all
the doors
so fast forward to the present day we
have situations where
newspapers like the one you you worked
for here are actually willing to work
with whistleblowers and and bring out
information that maybe in the past they
wouldn't have done as as quickly
although we do have the Pentagon papers
says and I helped work on the Pentagon
papers we were ready to do it the times
was ready to do it at any time if they
could confirm the information you know
we got the Pentagon papers dumped but we
rented two floors of a hotel over here
for a month embedded that data ourselves
so we did our own reporting Mr erlichman
are you telling me at the break-in to Dr
fielding's office was to satisfy the
president of the United States the
president wanted very much to make sure
that a thing like this could not happen
again
how one learned
whether Ellsberg acted alone as a
disgruntled employee of a think tank
whether he acted as a member of an
international spiring delivering secrets
to a foreign Embassy or just what his
role was where he fed had to be
determined in the opinion of the
investigators by every available means
do you have a sense of mission which is
unusual in journalism a sense of you
know you're actually uncovering
something of value and importance to the
American people that's the only reason
to be a journalist I mean democracy you
know as well as I do democracy only
survives
on a population that has the kind of
information that allows him to make a
decision to help make a democracy work
and if the Press doesn't do it who will
this is not just an American problem
journalists in other countries are being
spied on too by the NSA and their own
intelligence agencies says Tim McNulty
if you look at journalists in other
countries they risk a great deal more
than we risk we may be you know
prosecuted or we may it and end up with
adverse publicity or things like that
but we rarely feel that our lives are
threatened that our livelihoods are
threatened that our families the
journalists in many other countries are
not only more aggressive they're more
courageous this sources and secrets
conference included exchanges with
representatives of the intelligence
Community who argued that whistleblowers
like Edward Snowden should be in prison
it is my personal opinion Jim reisen
called me out on this that people who
leak classified information commit
crimes and if we can catch them which is
not always easy we ought to prosecute
them and they ought to go to jail here's
Robert lid who's general counsel for the
Director of National Intelligence there
are many many things the government
believes need to be kept secret secret
in the National interest and there's a
full recognition of the fact that the
Press is almost invariably going to
balance that interest different than the
government does and so there's going to
be necessarily an adversarial
relationship and the question is what
kind of processes can we set up to
ensure that that adversarial
relationship is a productive one rather
than a destructive one the panels also
included journalists who have been
disseminating and publishing Secrets
leaked by Snowden like the Washington
Post Barton Gilman and Independence like
Glenn Greenwald and Laura poitras Edward
Snowden is a rock star to some to others
of course he is a traitor and here today
um via Skype we have the three
journalists who were entrusted uh by
Snowden chosen by Snowden to be the
recipients of top secret NSA archives
do you feel it's essential do you
systematically run by the government ask
for government response on the stories
you've done on the Snowden Revelations
or other stories about the NSA we've had
the legal framework since I don't know
the Alien and Sedition Act and the
Espionage Act of 97 years ago
uh with which a government could
prosecute journalists for talking about
secrets and it has been a legal culture
a political culture that's created the
barriers to that Greenwald and poitras
have worked directly with leading
newspapers to report Secrets buried in
these documents he did not think that he
should be in the position to decide
which documents ought to be published
and which ones ought to be suppressed he
came to well-established and
well-regarded newspapers and asked the
journalists in those institutions with
whom he was working to make those
judgments about what is in the public
interest to publish and what is not and
specifically at least to me said a lot
of what I'm giving you is for background
for contacts for understanding
um but I don't think all of this should
be published if I just wanted all of
this published I wouldn't need you guys
I could have just uploaded it to the
internet
myself the thing that has I think been
um positive in terms of snowden's
disclosures is that it's reawakened and
adversarial um press and and that people
have been shocked that these things
these decisions about surveillance have
been made completely in secret
completely without public debate
and um and and that there does seem to
be some kind of an Awakening but I I
don't I wouldn't call it a shift of the
pendulum
and now an initially skeptical American
Media has showered them with top prizes
Greenwald poitrus and Gelman won the
admired poke Awards the next question
would the media honor Edward snowden's
contribution as a whistleblower in the
end they didn't but newspapers that
carried his leaks did win the even more
prestigious Pulitzer Prize
these reports were not always picked up
or praised because establishment
journalism does not trust Crusaders like
Greenwald and poitrus says Rory O'Connor
of Stony Brook University because
they're too independent and because even
as you heard the editors of the top
publications of the New York Times The
Washington Post in New Yorker and so on
all of them said on the panels today in
fact that they have not been aggressive
enough that they have collaborated
perhaps too much with the government in
the past these are the people who won
the major media organizations being
self-critical and saying no we don't
need to have more humility which is what
was suggested by Mr lit the
representative of the NSA and the and
the CIA he said that the Press needed
more humility I was pleased at least
that the leaders of the mainstream
organization struck back against that
and said no we don't need more humility
we need more aggressive reporting and I
agree with that before the big prize was
given Publications like the magazine
Politico framed the challenge facing the
powers who run establishment journalism
wrote media critic Dylan Byers honoring
the NSA reporting would inevitably be
perceived as a political act with the
Pulitzer committee invoking its prestige
on behalf of one side in a bitter
National argument yet to pass on the NSA
story would be to risk giving the
appearance of timidity the major media
resolved the debate this way they
recognized the Snowden disclosures
without recognizing him or the people
closest to him
Snowden was magnanimous seeing today's
decision is a Vindication for everyone
who believes that the public has a role
in government we owe it to the efforts
of Brave reporters and their colleagues
who keep working in the face of
extraordinary intimidation
Ben Wisner snowden's lawyer from the
American civil liberties Union also
praised the Press I do think that the
last year in particular has been an
extraordinary year for journalists
particularly American journalists that
that they have been you know courageous
in standing up in the face of government
claims of National Security that they
have not ignored those government claims
they have redacted stories where
appropriate but in general you know they
understood that the balance had tipped
far too much towards deference has the
big media now recognize the value of
whistleblowers in the Press other media
Outlets say they have to be more
aggressive in their own reporting and
not just rely on documents that are
leaked Jonathan landay is an
investigative reporter for the
Washington Bureau of McClatchy
newspapers I don't email sources
we just broke the story on the big fight
between the CIA and the Senate
intelligence committee most of the
groundbreaking work on that was done by
a 22 year old freelance paid freelancer
who did nothing but doorstep
committees on on the hill go to people's
homes got me doing that again going out
at night to visit people and and and
that's how we were able to do that
without and without sort of like sitting
in the office and taking phone calls the
issues at this conference on the rights
of the press also deal with another
right I think the right of the public to
be info formed about what governments do
in their name that's the focus of Amy
Goodman's concern
Goodman is an anchor of a popular
independent daily newscast called
democracy Now
information is the oxygen of a democracy
it's not just about participating in
Democratic processes it's about being
informed that's what makes democracy
meaningful and when we don't have that
information when a very powerful entity
the government has the information and
the people don't that is not a very
healthy sign it does not bode well for
democracy Goodman is a strong believer
in the Freedom of Information Act that
guarantees access to government
information when the ACT is respected
she cites one current example of the
government insisting on keeping secrets
something that happened 60 years ago the
issue is the U.S rule if any in the
arrest of South Africa's late leader
Nelson Mandela in 1962.
Ryan Shapiro an MIT graduate student is
now suing for the information after the
government turned down his request
Ryan Shapiro the graduate student at MIT
has sued for more information under the
Freedom of Information Act than anyone
in U.S history and one of the issues he
cares deeply about is what happened to
Nelson Mandela how was it that he was
picked up in the early 60s was it just
the South African government or it was
was Nelson Mandela targeted by the CIA
and intelligence given over to the South
African apartheid regime and why is it
that something that took place more than
half a century ago we not we can't learn
about today that is a very serious
question that doesn't have to do with
National Security that has to do with
embarrassment and that is not acceptable
in the end this is a fight to keep the
public informed you don't just achieve
democracy people have to fight for it
every single day have to be ever
vigilant
so now that the information is out there
and we don't even have all of the
information people have to decide what
they want to do how much power they want
to imbue in the government so what will
come from calls to action like Amy
Goodman's and mainstream media
conferences the crying the problem
you know I think nothing will come out
of events like this honestly to answer
your question you know the final panel
was uh was entitled where do we go from
here but actually it was very very
little of anyone addressing where we go
from here where to stay here in the
United States right now where the Press
is under attack by the Obama
Administration a greater attack than of
any previous administration in fact in
all previous administrations rolled
together and so what the question is
where does the media Go From Here faced
with this attack faced with the threat
of a further imprisonment on the part of
uh you know times reporters like Jim
Rising you know the mainstream media
themselves are under attack and I think
that would one thing I'm hoping you're
going to see is a greater Unity among
the media NSA whistleblowers like Russ
Tice say that the NSA at first labeled
him paranoid to discredit him with the
press paranoid is right they use
Paranoid and they did it on purpose I
think because they realized that if I
ever did go to the Press that's exactly
what they would say to the Press because
remember back then there aren't any I'm
the original NSA
you know uh whistleblower when this with
this sort of thing this is you know 2004
2005 time frame so you know when I
finally did come out that's exactly what
they did they said you're talking to a
crazy guy do you want your source to be
the crazy guy you know you know so in
other words even though you had
information and speculation that was
informed they basically attempted to
discredit you of course yes
but now whistleblowers are fighting back
by working together and getting society
and the media to recognize their
contribution another recent award named
after Ron Ridenour a soldier who exposed
the migai massacre in Vietnam in which
U.S soldiers slaughtered Villages and
children saluted at Snowden and the
reporters bringing his documents to the
public
I'm very happy to be here very honored
to be here to make this introduction to
two Extraordinary People Laura poitrus
and Edward Snowden author James Bamford
the first to expose NSA activities
introduce the winners a live message by
Ed Snowden now living in Exxon and
Russia was heard do you think it's right
that the NSA is collecting more
information about Americans in America
than it is about Russians in Russia
because that's what our systems do
we watch our own people more closely
than we watch any other population in
the world despite the protections
they are policy based the Technical
Systems ingest and collect everyone in
this room's uh communication when you
pick up the phone when you make a call
when you make a purchase when you buy a
book all of that is collected and I
could see it at my desk crossing my
screen
former CIA analyst Ray McGovern says
that journalists are not the only ones
who fear the power of the NSA then you
ask about the journalists you're asking
about Well everybody's afraid I mean
it's not just the journalists it's
people like Barack Obama
it's people like Dianne Feinstein think
about what the NSA has on Dianne
Feinstein and her husband
who has made billions from defense and
post office and all kinds of nice cozy
contracts okay so everybody's afraid not
just journalists let me just understand
this you're saying that President Obama
in your opinion informed opinion
has reasons to fear the power of the NSA
has to be careful in terms of the dance
he's done about yes he'll reform it but
not too much
well Danny when you're collecting
everything on everybody you know who who
Among Us is as pure as Caesar's wife you
know everybody's got something to hide
that's you know that's the it issue of
these people who say I got nothing to
hide you know well you know everyone has
things they want to hide
coming up next in our surveillance
series
the interface between the spy agencies
and the technology companies can their
cooperation be considered complicity in
spying do they violate the trust of
customers next
[Music]
thank you